die junge union hat beim deutschlandtag
in münster mit den spitzen von cdu und
csu
abgerechnet das muss man so sagen der
unions nachwuchs hat den parteiposten
einmal so richtig den marsch geblasen
und mild meinung chef philippe piatti
war dabei philipp dein eindruck ja also
der deutschlandtag in münster wird
glaube ich wirklich in die geschichte
eingehen zwar in die geschichte der cdu
normalerweise laufen deutschland tage
der jungen union zwar so ab dass es
schon ein bisschen deftiger zur sache
geht das hier und da auch mal klartext
gesprochen wird aber jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt einige wochen nach der
historischen niederlage
da waren die wirklich komplett auf
krawall auf abrechnung gebürstet und
zwar zu recht da haben sich die ganzen
partei browser hingestellt von
generalsekretär pozzi merck über
gesundheitsminister jens spahn bis hin
zu unions fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus
und die haben so eine kritik abbekommen
die sie vermutlich in ihrem leben noch
nie gehört haben und ich würde
vorschlagen wir schauen uns ein video
einmal an jahren also lange spannend
alle vorlesen okay die mitglieder der
umsatz der in deutschland mit digitalen
dienstleistungen erzielt werden soll
wird soll ich eine nationale steuer
erhoben werden die union keine position
chinesische firmen sollen keine aufträge
für den ausbau der
kommunikationsinfrastruktur in
deutschland erhalten die union keine
position ökologische landwirtschaft soll
stärker gefördert werden als konstant
wirtschaft die union keine position der
gesetzliche mindestlohn soll im jahr
2022 erhöht werden new york eine
position sein sorry
anfang der anfang ist das problem sorry
also
ja dann hat alles werden freundlich
geschmack ist dahinter genau du hast du
nun mit gips frederik paul hat er
wirklich einmal dampf abgelassen konkret
ging es um den wahl o maten ja und der
wahlomat wird von millionen menschen
gemacht gerade von den jüngeren und die
union war sich offenbar zu fein irgendwo
1 anzukreuzen wie sie denn zu den
sachverhalten steht beziehungsweise hat
gesagt na ja wir sehen das
differenzierter man kann hier nicht mit
ja oder mit nein antworten also und
kilian polymer opposition und er hat das
einfach mal vorgelesen und der saal hat
natürlich getobt und während er das
vorgelesen hat standen vorne auf der
bühne die zwei generalsekretäre paul
signac von der cdu und markus blume von
der csu und die kam so richtig ins
schwitzen wenn da einer aufgestanden
wäre und gesagt hätte rücktritt mein
gott wir wissen nicht was da passiert
wäre da hätte der saal vermutlich geholt
man muss dazusagen pauls ii merck hat
sehr emotional dann geantwortet konnte
sich gerade noch retten aber die
stimmung im saal die bald komplett gegen
die cdu-granden und aufseiten der jugend
die ads klarmachen wollte der wahlkampf
den habt ihr komplett in den sand
gesetzt und wir leiden darunter und wir
zeigen euch jetzt wie es geht und
besonders bitter wurde es dann gestern
als unions fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus
gesprochen hatten relativ
leidenschaftliche rede gehalten spricht
auch immer sehr energisch in seinem
seinem bariton aber auch er hat glaube
ich nicht damit gerechnet was ihm dann
entgegen geschleudert wurde und zwar ist
ein juhu mitglied aufgestanden und hat
gesagt herr brinkhaus was glauben sie
eigentlich wie gefährlich was bedeutet
die ampel für die bundeswehr ganz kurz
bitte antworten machen brinkhaus gesagt
ja das alles ganz schlimm für die
bundeswehr mit der ampel tja und dann
hat das j um mitglied einmal richtig
losgelegt da sollten wir auch einmal
reinhören
mich hat gewundert dass das thema
bundeswehr bisher noch keine rolle
gespielt hat weil wir müssen mal sehr
kritisch mit uns zwar seien sie reden
hier freuen die ganze zeit eigentlich
ich wunder mich ein bisschen wie ein
oppositionsführer also in den letzten
drei jahren wir müssen uns mal ehrlich
machen wir sind so einer partei geworden
die auf sonntagsreden die bundeswehr
lobt und gerne von herzblut zum beispiel
spricht von verständnis die aber nicht
in der lage hessen 16 jahren die
bundeswehr auszustatten
zu
reformieren effizienter zu machen wenn
dann aber wenn es dann heiß wird wenn
kugeln cargoline ein flughafen gesichert
werden muss dann schreiben wir nach der
bundeswehr dass sie mal machen soll und
dann sind wir noch so dreist unser
eigenes politisches versagen es war
nicht die anderen die in der regierung
waren ist da ein bier die es nicht
geschafft haben die bundeswehr
auszustatten dann sind wir noch so
dreist unser eigenes politisches
versagen auf die politischen gegner
abzuschieben und ihn jetzt die kompetenz
oder die verantwortung auf die nächsten
jahre in die zukunft
um zu sparen
[Musik]
so deswegen würde ich sie einfach unten
meine frage habe ich vorher gestellt
machen sie sich mal ehrlich hinterfragen
sie sich mal selber was sie gemacht
haben die sie mal ins stille kämmerlein
und dann und wenn sie das gemacht haben
ja dann können sie mal darüber
nachdenken wie sie sich vielleicht auch
mal wieder vor bundeswehrsoldaten
stellen sollen wie sie dass ihnen dann
auch glaubwürdig verkaufen können dass
sie sich für diese interessen einsetzen
danke
philipp sind das scharfe worte natürlich
sind das sozusagen jetzt spontane
einzelmeinungen auch aus der
enttäuschung heraus oder wächst da jetzt
ein richtiger druck von unten von der
jugend auch heran ich glaube dass hier
etwas ausgesprochen wurde was ganz viele
in der union schon seit jahren denken
man hat das aber nicht gesagt weil man
das kanzleramt hatte weil man regiert
hat und wenn man sich dachte na ja
selbst ohne richtiges programm ohne
richtige inhalte ohne richtige
überzeugung ohne tolles personal schafft
man das einfach weiter an der macht zu
bleiben und diese wahl hat hat gezeigt
das geht so nicht und jetzt wurde
einfach mal wirklich abgerechnet alles
was sich in letzten jahren angestaut hat
kam hier erst mal zum vorschein das
waren jetzt die jungen die da
abgerechnet haben glaubst du diese phase
der abrechnung hat bei der union jetzt
erst begonnen kommt da noch mehr
hinterher oder was jetzt erst noch nein
ich glaube da ehrlich gesagt das war nur
die allererste runde und die junge union
hat jetzt erst mal den startschuss
gegeben aber es gab wahnsinnig viel
zustimmung von den älteren also ich habe
mit vielen cdu-nahen kommuniziert leuten
die schon seit jahrzehnten in der partei
sind und die haben diesen deutschlandtag
mit großer großer zustimmung und
heimlicher freude geschaut was da die
parteigranden abbekommen haben das hat
ganz viele in der union gefreut hatten
ja sogar noch köpfe rollen
es werden auf jeden fall köpferollen
fragt sich natürlich nur welche und ob
die karrieren dann wirklich komplett zu
ende gehen oder ob manche leute kurz mal
in die zweite dritte reihe zurücktreten
müssen aber ralph brinkhaus der hat zum
beispiel gestern richtige bewerbungsrede
gehalten das ist der frack und chef der
union der will das auch bleiben man
munkelt dass er vielleicht noch mehr
will das ja vielleicht auch parteichef
werden will und deswegen hat er gestern
wirklich versucht dazu pumpen mit ganz
viel klartext oder das was er darunter
versteht hat die ampel als stramm linkes
programm
bezeichnet er dachte dass er damit
landen kann und er wurde komplett
auseinandergenommen also wenn das
wirklich die bewerbungsrede für den
parteivorsitz vom von herrn brinkhaus
war dann ist das richtig in die hose
gegangen er repräsentiert er nur noch
nicht die zukunft war ja auch vorher
schon fraktionschef wer hat den meisten
applaus bekommen wenn man danach mal
urteilen würde war dass wir uns sparen
oder werber da ganz vorn ja also die
wichtigsten reden in der im
bewerbungsprozess um den cdu-vorsitz kam
von wie gesagt ralph brinkhaus dann jens
spahn und friedrich merz und man muss
sagen sparen hat sich da am besten
geschlagen der hat sich demütig gegeben
und hat ohne viel neues zu verkünden
einfach mal rekapituliert wofür die
union eigentlich steht und das hat
irgendwie die stimmung im saal erfasst
die leute haben ganz viel geklatscht er
wurde dann auch nicht so hart angefasst
haben muss sich sparen doch selber
eigentlich politisch jede menge
vorwerfen lassen eigentlich was er so
alles angerichtet hat in den letzten
wochen und monaten in der korona
pandemie absolut corona pandemie er war
auch im team laschet damals aber sparen
steht immer noch für eine art aufbruch
auch wenn er seit 20 jahren schon im
bundestag ist schon ganz lange in den
wichtigsten gremien der partei vertreten
ist der steht immer noch für einen
gewissen aufbruch und friedrich merz hat
seine rede muss man sagen wirklich
komplett versemmelt denn dieser märz
mythos wackelt einfach er hat jetzt zwei
mal verloren als er selbst cdu-chef
werden wollte dann hat er einmal mit
armin laschet die kanzlerkandidatur
verloren herzliche felsenfest hinter
laschet gestellt und man merkt die leute
die höheren dem zu auch mit einer
gewissen sympathie wurde kaum geklatscht
diese diese bedeutungsschwere die märz
immer mitbringt ohne viel neues zu
erzählen die scheint einfach abhanden zu
kommen darauf warten die leute da keine
lust mehr und handyverbot wurde übrigens
auch wieder einkassierte absolut also
das handyverbot waren wir ein absolutes
desaster für für armin laschet
er kam da an und hat diese rede gehalten
hat gesagt solange ich parteichefin wird
in den gremien ein handyverbot geben man
muss sagen dafür gab es auch viel
applaus die durchstechereien gerade an
bild waren riesen riesenthema ein
mitglied hat zum beispiel gesagt wenn im
cdu-präsidium die loyalität gegenüber
paul ronzheimer größer ist als gegenüber
der partei dann sollen diese leute bitte
verschwinden also das ging schon echt ab
aber als ich dann selbst drüber
diskutiert hat obmann handy und andere
digitale endgeräte verbieten soll in
vorstandssitzungen haben die gesagt es
geht doch nicht wir sind im 21
jahrhundert wir haben unsere sitzungen
doch alle digital wie soll ich denn wir
sollten darauf achten dass ich mein
handy weglegen wenn ich gerade am laptop
sitzen und über sumann der
konferenzteilnehmer wollen wir jetzt
wirklich anfangen dinge auszudrucken
also das war wieder ein vorschlag von
armin laschet der erst mal für applaus
sorgt aber einfach überhaupt nicht
funktioniert
[Musik]